Nickelodeon fans rejoice Drake Bell just
teased a possible Drake & Josh reunion
and we are freaking out I would love to
do it and I'm sure he would too
he caught up with a singer over the
weekend at Knott's Scary Farm in Orange
County California and he reveals what's
next for the two now that they rekindled
their friendship earlier this year when
are we gonna see you guys reunite in an
acting capacity we're doing great right
now and I actually just had dinner with
him and his wife before before I left
for tour and I mean I would love to do
it and I'm sure he would too so I don't
want to give anything away you guys
talked about it though yes we definitely
have yeah I mean yeah how can we not you
know it's the the the the reunion that
we had and and and the reaction that it
got was was just incredible and and it
shows that the fans are still out there
they still love it and and and we'd love
to get back together and you know put
the whole put the band back together you
know but you had some beef over the
summer when Peck married his longtime
girlfriend Paige O'Brien apparently
without inviting his friend Bell took to
social media to express his upset in a
series of sense deleted tweets that
quickly went viral but in September the
former co-stars made up
hi guys there you have it there it is
it's all love honestly I think it would
be something I would love to do
something completely different I love
the guy and and we work great together
so anything in any capacity I'd be happy
to do with him that I'm sure is gonna
make so many fans so ecstatic thank you
yeah it's like a relationship like that
in this business is so
once-in-a-lifetime that how can you let
it go but it's you know we're brothers
so we have our ups we have our downs but
right now we're doing incredible
you